what you're about to watch is a clip
from my brand lytics training where i
get together with entrepreneurs thought
leaders who want to build their brand
using youtube and making data driven
decisions to blow up their brand this
year enjoy
hack your network so
this one
is
very valuable because there's probably
people who you're connected to
that you you don't even know that you're
connected to
and so there's a couple ways to look at
this the first is through youtube so on
youtube
if you go to your dashboard there's a
little card that shows you your recent
subscribers so last 90 days it'll show
you here last 90 days and i'll show you
who subscribed to your channel so when i
go to mine i see that cochi dannymac
global video pro one all subscribed to
my channel in the past 90 days and what
they do is they sorted by
the channels with the biggest
subscribers so all of you right now
could go do this or after this after
this session you can go look at your own
channel and see who has subscribed to
your channel because these people are
going to be
easier to do collaborations with if you
reach out to them you find out their
email address or instagram handle it's a
lot easier to get a yes because they
already know who you are they already
like you because they've subscribed to
your channel and so it's much easier
outreach you can then click that see all
button
and everybody should have this card this
was an experimental card a while back
but everybody should have this now it's
kind of buried on the page so you got to
scroll down so dashboard and then scroll
down find recent subscribers and then
click see all so then you click see all
and what happens is it'll take you to
uh a giant page and you can switch it to
lifetime so at the top it defaults to 90
days but then you can switch it to night
to lifetime and then this will show you
everybody who has subscribed to your
channel that has um
significant subscriber count so this is
mine right this person is 5 million 5
million 3 million 2 million 2 million
1 million or whatever 2 million 2
million we're getting there um
so of this list the only one that i've
done it with is tom
so i've done
a couple of collaborations with tom uh
in the past and he he was gracious
enough to read a section of my book
built a serve and and use that for our
promo pieces um the other ones i haven't
i haven't i just i i
undervalue
this strategy
uh the amount of work to kind of reach
out and and then back and forth i just
um i just haven't prioritized it i don't
i don't see it as a huge win
um even though some of these channels
are bigger than me right i'm at i'm
almost at three so we've got three of
these channels that are bigger than me
this one is almost double my ch my size
i don't know what she does i think she's
more like lifestyle
in russia or something
this guy does cartoon
psychology uh i don't remember what
gavin does i think it's lifestyle
vlogging kind of thing
um so
it requires some creativity right if if
chris is finding that there's a
fortnight channel that is
subscribed to him and and there they've
got an audience well maybe your music
could be on in the background for his
next fortnight series
okay maybe maybe we make a
a special playlist for him that's an
hour of
of your music back to back and he has a
special maybe he even streams with you
maybe you learn fortnight or maybe
you're already a pro at fortnight and
you do a session together
right and your music's on in the
background that kind of collaboration
if you find it fun it could be it could
be really good
um again the work is set up so now it's
thinking about what's the value that you
could bring their channel
like what are you an expert at that they
need help with that they're not good at
that they could use some content for
first off if you go to their about page
there's usually some kind of contact
information like you go to youtube look
at their channel and there's there's an
about tab click on that it'll show you
contact information typically for them
often it's an email if not there then
you've got a twitter or instagram
account that you can connect to that's
how you reach out and say hey thank you
hey it's nicola thank you so much for
subscribing to my channel it's awesome
do you want to do some kind of
collaboration together i i'd love to
make a video on your channel about one
two three right so you look at their
channel you see what they're great at
and don't just do the exact same thing
that they're great at because that's
competitive but what are they missing
and then those could be topics for you
to be able to reach out to and share i
remember i did one
with a woman who's doing
a lot of lifestyle vlogging stuff and
we're trying to find uh
an angle like how do we how do we work
this out and it turns out she loved
shark tank and she didn't understand a
lot of the terminology on shark tank
a lot of the language a lot of the deal
making she doesn't understand what kevin
o'leary was saying
so
i said okay give me a list of the 10
words there are 10 phrases that that you
hear a lot that you don't really
understand what it means and i'll make a
video explaining what those 10 things
mean
so that was the kind of collaboration
that we ended up doing for her channel
um there was a dating guy called the
josh speaks who's got a couple hundred
thousand on his channel
and he's like i'm not really the dating
guy dude i don't know what we're gonna
do together
i don't have a lot of dating advice to
share um so so i made one about
about belief and confidence
and then how that can impact your entire
life and so like it
sometimes it requires a little bit of
creativity to make it happen
uh sometimes it's super direct and easy
terry says i'm going to look at mine
when i get back home i love it i can
definitely see the opportunity in doing
more podcast live stream interviews yeah
especially if you're the one being
interviewed that's even better because
you're on their channel
um
you know for for most of mine i mix it
up actually i mean i had i had tony
robbins on my channel he hasn't
interviewed me for his channel
yet
anna says i get a lot of invites for
podcast collabs and some i feel excited
about but i need a polite way to say no
to some um
i figure what my default response is
uh
but you can you can it's easy just to
say you've got you're full up right now
i mean i would say something like that
like i'm just i'm full up right now i
don't have a space right now you can
reach back out in
in um
in a month and two months whatever and
sometimes i like putting up hoops for
people and then see if they jump through
one i'm going to share an example of a
guy named brandon later on in this
presentation and and i i threw him
through some hoops
like do this do this do this and and he
did them it's like you know what
i like this guy
you know what this i'm gonna give this
guy a shot let's go
so one simple one is
uh i do a live stream
four days a week with drew at night and
uh and another co-host zanda man and we
answer business questions from the
audience
and so if somebody
out of the blue messages me evan do you
want to come on my podcast and i have no
idea who they are and it's not some big
podcast i'll say hey uh our default
response on instagram would be evan gets
a lot of dms he can't answer everyone
personally but if you join him on his
live stream tonight you can ask him this
is your chance to ask a question
and most people never show up most
people don't do it
like it's a free live stream happening
tonight you get to ask evan if you're
not going to spend the eight minutes to
show up at that time then i'm not going
to invest the time to you know come on
your show or your podcast so you throw a
couple hoops in there just to weed out
the people who are actually
interested in it generally interested in
it and we'll do the work um and i like i
just love supporting those people
i'm making it happen
um so yeah just saying that you're
you're full up whether it's now it's my
team doing it
uh
well they'll respond typically
saying that hey evan's full up right now
but join him on his live stream but it
could be you as well i mean i'll do it
with some people there there are a bunch
of things i have to say no to it
it's hard
it's hard to say no to people but at the
same time you have to protect your
your time and your energy and the work
that you're doing
uh terry says
your gaming live stream is awesome a
great way to engage
yeah
it's super fun and and some people do
show up and the people who do they get
the extra love and the people who don't
want to put in the little bit of extra
work it's not like i'm asking hey
um
buy this thousand dollar ticket and you
might get a chance to talk to evan right
it's like no this is a free thing
happening tonight come by
it's a little bit inconvenient maybe for
your time but we're we're going for an
hour and a half two hours four times a
week pick a time come on out and ask
kevin your questions
so anyway so how can your network right
there's probably people already most
people don't do this most people didn't
even know this feature existed right did
you guys know this even existed
on youtube
so
you can look at it and if you just
scroll down every now and then to to
this one on your page
this keeps updating this is on your
dashboard
right so you can just every now and then
just scroll down and it'll show you an
if any three new ones that are big
subscribe to your channel and the faster
you catch it the easier it is to do some
kind of collaboration with
right unfortunately there's no
notifications at least that i know of to
be alerted
big channel i'll just subscribe to you
but um at least this is now this used to
be a lot harder to find out who is
subscribed to your channel because you
just see a number
but
anyway these are great potential
collaborations to reach out to and just
keep keep track of we can just go cold
we can just say here's my dream list
here's my bucket list here's my ideal
100 that i want to reach out to and
uh start working towards them but in
easier ways people who you're already
connected to who you may not ever have
heard of but they've got an audience and
you can do something with them if you
want to see this full video as well as
train live with me twice a month to blow
up your brand join the brand linux
training program there's a link to join
right there next to me continue to
believe i'll see you there